emilie marsh merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe ur rt france alors
après les prêts les paroles du président
hier comment avez vous reçu ce discours
de politique générale prononcé par le
premier ministre avec en pointe on le
rappelle la lutte contre le chômage
comme priorité absolue la lutte contre
le chômage ça fait plus de trente cinq
ans plus de 40 ans qu'on l'entend après
c'est comme on fait et honnêtement quand
monde voici une longue liste de courses
sans stratégie avec des choses quand
même sur l'industrie enfin on se rend
compte que notre industrie est perdu
mais à qui la faute sur les fleurons
industriels perdus emmanuel macron en
est la première cause alstom
c'est lui qui a vendu le bijou d'alstom
aux américains general electric
c'est lui qui a laissé perdu fait partir
les turbines hydrauliques à grenoble
c'est lui qui laisse tomber belfort et
c'est lui qui son gouvernement
il ya quelques jours pour signer un
accord laisse partir lusine qui ait
reconquis construire noté m dans le bas
rhin
donc moi j'attends des actes et une
réelle lama tg industrie du jeu
finalement avec ce plan pour l'industrie
vous estimez que le gouvernement fait un
peu marche arrière finalement moi
j'attends les actes parce que les
paroles on les entend beaucoup moi
j'attends les actes moi j'attends déjà
que on sauve les entreprises qui sont à
sauver existantes par exemple luxe faire
un une usine qui est le dernier
fabricant de l'union européenne des
bombes aux deux de gaz d'oxygène pour
nos hôpitaux dont les malades du code
vide en ont besoin bacon la saucisse a
fait dix neuf mois que les salariés se
battent pour la sauver et ont trouvé des
repreneurs donc déjà qu'on le fasse ou
qu'on l'a réquisitionne au moins le
temps qu'on puisse reproduire au plus
vite que la vente se fasse
voilà ça serait un acte que l' usine du
bas rhin qui qui produit noté er bas
restent dans le bas rhin qu'on a
qu'on en mette plus parce qu'on en a
besoin plus de rénover nos thés verts
que nos petites lignes soit réellement
sauvé et qui est de l'investissement que
par exemple il parle d'écologie bas ont
mis plus de trains et moi de camions
donc qu la réouverture du perpignan
rungis que celle qui est menacé par
exemple dans ma région en auvergne
volvic mont d'or soit soit sauvé donc en
fait on attend les actes pour pouvoir
les croire parce que leur parole ne
suffit plus malheureusement ils ont
prouvé qu'ils aient pas grand chose vous
reveniez à l'instant sur le dossier de
l'écologie justement l'écologie doit
être créatrice de richesses je le cite a
souligné jean castex il a affirmé croire
on la croissance écologique mais pas à
la décroissance verte est ce que vous
leur et joignez sur ses propos n'ont pas
du tout bas c'est le vieux dogmatisme
néolibéral qu'on entend depuis un petit
moment en dix ans par la croissance
verte la croissance verte
après mois sur l'écologie on doit avoir
un facteur il en a pas parlé c'est sur
l'eau parce que l'eau on en manque de
plus en plus on a la moitié des
départements qui sont quand même en zone
sécheresse et qui arrive de de plus en
plus vite
moi j'habite à grenoble et on voit bien
qu'il ya moins en moins de neige donc à
un moment donné comme on fait par
rapport à ça parce que l'ol va on va en
manquer même pour juste pouvoir boire se
nourrir ou se laver donc comme on fait
par rapport à ça et honnêtement on
n'aura pas une politique écologique en
continent avec les agriculteurs et
glyphosate voilà il faut il faut toute
une stratégie aussi là pour revenir à
une agriculture locale et paysages
ailleurs il n'en a parlé de cette
agriculture plus local d'ailleurs qui le
souhaitent oui mais sans pesticides
aussi et avec un accompagnement des
agriculteurs et qu'ils soient aidés et
en sortir avec l'agriculture intensive
ça il en a quand même beaucoup moins
parler est pareil on attend on attend
des actes
et dz par rapport à ça et honnêtement on
peut pas avoir une politique écologique
en prônant le développement de la 5g qui
en cours d'émission co2 et de déchets de
beaucoup de choses alors emmanuel macron
a parlé hier à d'un nouveau chemin on a
entendu un aujourd'hui plus d'efforts
pour les jeunes plus de décentralisation
plus de laïcité dans les écoles aussi la
lutte contre les incivilités également
est ce que vous avez senti un changement
de cap
aujourd'hui non pas pas vraiment faim
sur on attends moi comme je vous dis on
attend on attend les actes après
emmanuel macron avait dit au moment du
confinement qu'il avait changé qu'on
serait dans le monde d'après là on voit
quand même que le monde d'après il
ressemble beaucoup au monde avant et
même au monde d'avant d'avant et donc du
coup on attend on attend vraiment
on attendait vraiment une bifurcation on
attendait quand même que pour de
l'industrie ou pour l'économie on parle
on parle des besoins et pas de de cette
politique de l'offre qui est mortifère
tant sur un plan écologique que sur un
plan économique qu'on est sur la
décentralisation
encore une nouvelle décentralisation on
ne sait pas où comment et on sait pas
aussi parce que quand on décentralise
souvent il n'y a pas les moyens derrière
que ça soit pour les régions pour les
départements pour les communes et aussi
pour pas que ça ait une concurrence
entre les territoires parce que ça soit
les régions les départements ou les
communes il ya des communes qui sont
plus riches que d'autres
il est hors de question que ya une
différence peu importe on habite sur le
territoire et moi il ya il ya quelque
chose qui bouge et pas entendu le mot ce
qui s'appelle les services publics il ya
où il ya eu à aucun moment le nouveau
premier ministre qui a parlé de la
défense des services publics qui est
aussi un point d'égalité au des
territoires extrêmement important et
sans service public qui a pas de
république
alors jean castex a également annoncé en
plus du ségur de la santé 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires d'investissement
dans le système de santé
est ce que cela est suffisant selon vous
pour calmer les soignants on l'a vu lui
manifester encore hier oui non non mais
ça les calmera pas parce que toute façon
ils demandaient une augmentation de
salaire ils ont une prime donc c'est pas
la même chose et la prime elle est même
pas à ce qu'ils demandaient rêve
toujours les soignants les moins payés
les moins bien payés de l'union
européenne et des pays de l' ocde ce qui
est quand même un scandale et ce qu'ils
on fait beaucoup de moyens et aussi de
personnel et que là on voit pas vraiment
et après il ya la réalité du terrain moi
quand je vois chez moi dans ma commune
ou ou une
une clinique mutualiste est en passe
d'être racheté par un groupe immobilier
en avons interpellé le ministre de la
santé qui est de cette ville qui est
grenoblois et où on n'a pas de réponse
donc en fait à un moment donné il faut
aussi il ya rien aussi dans la stratégie
pour avoir des médecins dans les zones
blanches parce que il ya de plus en plus
de français qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant
les jeunes ont également comme priorité
dans ce plan de relance avec notamment
des contrats d'insertion supplémentaires
comment est ce que vous percevez ce cap
là justement sur les jeunes d'abord
avant de parler des gens me disent oui
si une entreprise embauche un jeune elle
aura une aide
enfin honnêtement nous on a une aide
pour une entreprise quand on embauche un
jeune un jeune aussi celles à venir
assez en forme il va être là pendant
longtemps
non on rentre dans une crise où il ya
sept cent mille jeunes qui vont rentrer
sur le marché du travail et on leur
propose quand même pas pas grand chose
pourquoi on remet pas une politique
hommes avaient fait lionel jospin des
emplois jeunes qui avaient quand même
pas mal marché notamment aussi dans
l'est dans les services publics y aller
à les aider à y aller non là ce qu'on
propose c'est quand une entreprise
embauche un jeune et bat paf est la
déchargeant - sauf que des charges ce
qu'ils appellent des charges sociales en
fait c'est des cotisations sociales etc
de l'argent en moins dans les caisses de
l'état pour la sécurité sociale pour
payer nos retraites
et tout ça merci emilie marsh d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes conseillère et les filles de
la région auvergne rhône-alpes